so I was checking out the president's tweets
yesterday and I noticed Donald Trump say quote,
great job by Congressman Doug Collins of Georgia
over the weekend and representing the Republican
party and myself
against the impeachment hoax.
And I thought, what the heck?
Let's see what Trump's talking about.
If he liked it, it must be really weird and
case in point, Republican Congressman Doug
Collins was on Fox news Sunday over the weekend,
and it is everything that we could have imagined
and more.
Doug Collins goes on the strangest word salad
and defensive Donald Trump and it makes such
little sense that I actually decided to transcribe
it for you, which we will put up on the screen
momentarily.
This is what Donald Trump liked from Doug
Collins.
The fact of the is there corruption so I do
not spend dollars that I don't need to spend
in the Ukraine because of corruption.
It was still there was an issue.
Let me just ask you a thought experiment that
just, just bear with me for a minute.
If you believe that the president had used
the power of his office to try to get Ukraine
to interfere with our elections, if you believe
that, would that be an impeachable offense?
I do not believe it, so I'm not going to ask
her a hypothetical in which is designed to
simply say that the president did something
improper.
Chris, he did nothing in property.
There was nothing about a problematic giving
aid to another country in which you're talking
about corruption, which he's required to do
by law.
And it just so happened that a presidential
candidate, his son, who was getting an a massive
amount of money from a company that had been
under investigation in which even other witnesses
that had been favorable quote to the Democrats
in the investigation have said needed to be
looked at.
This is a problem of overall proportion, but
there's nothing here that the president did
wrong and this is the thing that we're going
to move forward on.
Okay?
Yeah.
So you really have to look at a transcript
to see how whacked this is, and I transcribed
it.
Take a look with me.
This is what a Doug Collins said, quote, I
do not believe it so that I'm not going to
answer a hypothetical in which is designed
to simply say that the president something
improper, Chris, he did nothing improper.
There is nothing about a problematic giving
aid to another country in which you're talking
about corruption, which he's required to do
by law.
And he just so happened that a presidential
candidate son who is getting in a massive
amount of money from a company that had been
under investigation in which me, even other
witnesses that have been for favorable quote
to the Democrats in the investigation have
said to be looked at, have said, needed to
be looked at.
Sorry, this is a problem of overall proportion,
but there's nothing here that the president
did wrong, and this is the thing that we're
going to move forward on.
I have no idea what this guy's talking about.
If anybody knows what he's talking about,
let me know.
Now I understand he's defending Trump and
he's suggesting that Donald Trump did nothing
wrong.
Like I understand the tone of it, but I don't
know what the hell this guy's talking about.
Now it's possible that he and Donald Trump
both speak whatever language that is, which
is why some people understood what Trump meant
by Cobb FEFI and Trump presumably understands
what this guy said, but it's got to be just
the tone.
It's seemed like this guy was strongly defending
Trump.
And I guess that that's good enough for Donald
There's nothing about a problematic giving
aid to another country in which you're talking
about corruption, which he's required to do
by law.
And I started thinking to myself, you know,
what has happened to education in our country?
What has happened to critical thinking in
our country?
But Doug Collins went to college.
He also has a master's degree, sort of, it's
a master's in divinity divinity from some
seminary, but still it's a master's degree.
Doug Collins is a lawyer.
He has a law degree and this incoherent word
salad, defensive Donald Trump is the best
that he was able to muster up.
Either something is very wrong with Doug Collins
or he's simply struggling to defend the indefensible
and his brain couldn't handle it.
So it resorted to something as nonsensical
as this.
And what you just heard, the saddest thing
about all of this is that people who want
to defend Donald Trump will watch this video
and they won't understand it because it doesn't
make any sense of course.
And they'll say to themselves, you know, this
Doug Collins guy, he seems super smart and
I just don't really understand politics.
He must just be talking in a way that is above
my head.
I'm sure he's making sense.
Many Trumpists will assume despite the fact
that this guy is making no sense whatsoever,
but it'll be enough for them.
A strong defense of Donald Trump.
Trump was happy with it.
Doug Collins seemingly pleased with it even
though it makes no sense whatsoever.
That's what Trump like.
That's what Trump found, uh, to be a great
job done by Congressman Doug Collins.
The discourse has been debased and I'm worried
there is no return, at least no return anytime
soon.
Facebook of is increasingly a bad actor in
the world of disseminating truth of prioritizing
fact over propaganda, uh, in the world of
limiting the destructive effect of actual
fake news and lies on the internet.
I don't mean fake news the way Trump uses
it, which is any news he doesn't like.
I mean actual disinflation propaganda